du côté de trappes ils font partie des
candidats engagés dans le scrutin
citoyen en actions est un collectif
d'habitants sans aucune appartenance
politique menée par un binôme bakou
keita tête de liste et youssef bouchikhi
leur objectif que les trappistes se
réapproprient leur ville et participe
activement à la vie de celle-ci -2 45%
des électeurs avaient participé au
scrutin des municipales de 2014 dans la
commune pour y parvenir si ton est un
action se base sur un socle de cinq
priorités jeunesse mettre en place par
exemple l'étude et le soutien scolaire
sociale lutter contre la précarité
emploi cadre de vie lutter notamment
contre la bétonisation une démarche qui
est guidé par une idée celle de la
démocratie locale écoutez pas vu des
trappes est gérée par des gens qui sont
pas issus trappe déjà et qui te
connaissent pas nos problèmes on a
beaucoup de difficulté à trappes niveau
logement social jeunesse etc
mais nous on veut mettre le point j'ai
vraiment travaillé
l'amélioration de tout ce à quoi on a
aujourd'hui 7500 sinus aux dernières
élections municipales pour six mille
votants c'est c'est tout simplement pas
possible ça veut forcément dire
mécaniquement que la population n'est
pas représenté dans son intégralité et
nous on veut mettre fin on veut mettre
fin à ça on veut réellement concernés
les gens on veut les inviter à revenir
aux urnes à se sentir concernés par la
ville tout simplement